senior NBA router Sports Illustrated
Chris Mannix how are you Chris you can't
say that rich because then I get a
little bit of punishment the other end
that's okay that's it mean punishment
with the wheel with that wheel well you
know what the wheel of punishment or or
like you know all taps on mouths no
together we have that as your hair
recovered from that by the way that your
Dan Patrick show bet yet are you fully
back are you back completely oh wait
it's like I was gonna say like Sampson
but that wouldn't be a good analogy but
it is back full strength right now
you're full strength
okay you're out of the penalty box okay
let's start with the Celtics obviously
since you are an NBC sports boston
employee as well as Sports Illustrated
what did you make of Marcus Morris
saying the Celtics are not having any
fun and all of our all of us in the
national media putting pieces together
to say that this is their window of
opportunity having having been shut
right now Chris what do you think well
it was surprising to hear what he said
on the end of a second straight double
digits giving up a double-digit lead in
a game too underwhelming team's Lakers
and the Clippers what was surprising was
how he seemed to indicate that it wasn't
just those past two games it was you
know a little bit of everything it was
the last two months maybe but you know
the bottom line with this team is that
they they just don't seem to be
connected and what I think that just
seems like they've got a collection of
young guys that are at one point in
their careers and want to do things one
way and veteran players are different
point their careers and maybe see things
a little bit differently they've never
quite made that connection between and
tough golf actions between the two
groups on that team have never seemed to
make that direct connection and and put
it all together now there's still a
belief within the team that they can do
that and the evidence of that is you win
back-to-back games you know Philadelphia
in the room it was a huge win then you
beat a Pistons team that's been fighting
for the playoffs on the back end so
they've proven that they can do it when
they get the right together it's just
there's never any consistency we
this team as evidenced by the last
couple weeks and Kairi going back and
forth between voicing love for Boston
and then saying he doesn't owe anybody
anything and then also having a
realization about LeBron and what
LeBrons tough-love was actually
attempting to do and him calling him to
apologize where where does Tyrese
where's the temperature on Kyrie right
now you know it's really hard to gauge
you know you talk to people within the
organization and there some have a
steadfast belief that if Kyrie Irving
you have to remember is that three knee
surgeries in the last few years if he
gets a full five-year max contract off
from the Celtics which will push him I
think close to 200 million dollars that
he's going to take that there are others
that are extremely fearful of a Kevin
Durant let Knicks group that might also
have Simon Williamson or another top
three draft pick because they know that
Kyrie Irving from northern New Jersey
has a kind of a magnetic pole to New
York so there's kind of a split camp
there with in with some people I talked
to within the organizational what Kyrie
does everybody though rich will tell you
that if this team makes it deeper on the
playoffs that's gonna have a positive
impact on Kyrie Irving and 15 gets
bounced a in the second round that can
have an equally strong negative impact
well I mean this may be a chicken or egg
question but I've started the show by
saying that until somebody beats the
Warriors the drama is all about who's
putting the team together to beat the
Warriors and if they can use a warriors
player in free agency to do it all the
better and until that happens we're just
gonna be wondering about trade deadlines
and impending free agency during the
playing season just to keep us occupied
while we're all assuming the Warriors
are gonna win at all
how much of the decision-making has
actually been made since everybody
thinks Durant's going to the Knicks and
Kyrie might follow and klay Thompson
might come to the Lakers if Anthony
Davis can somehow go there how much of
this has actually already been decided
in their respective camps best you could
tell Chris you know I'm skeptical that
anything
has been decided strongest connection
you could make is Durant and the Knicks
because the Knicks after swearing for
the last year-plus
that they wouldn't behave exactly like
they just did turned around and went all
in on free agency for the second time in
a decade now we all know how that worked
out back in 2010 this time around they
took a massive risk in dealing away
kristaps porzingis a potential franchise
player to get them into that double max
free agency space so you read the tea
leaves they're rich and something has to
tell you that the Knicks
feel comfortable that Kevin Durant's
going to go there but anyone that's been
involved in the free agency process
either covering it or a part of it knows
that these meetings are incredibly
impactful I mean Kevin Durant chose
between Oklahoma City and Golden State
in part because of what happened in the
Hamptons and the meeting there and
really feeling comfortable with that
group what happens at the Knicks of a
meeting and they act like they did in
2010 was completely unprepared for
having that type of meeting with a
Dwyane Wade or LeBron James Dwyane Wade
said you know after the fact that he
didn't think after that meeting that the
Knicks were to take that team to the
next level what happens at Kevin Durant
does that and sees that from New York so
I'm just skeptical that anything has
really been decided until these guys sit
down with these teams and hear the whole
pitch well obviously Chris Mannix of
Sports Illustrated here on the Rich
Eisen show what happens with Anthony
Davis is going to be paramount and he
essentially said on NBA TV could be
anybody then everybody's on his list
except New Orleans right now and that
anything can possibly happen the only
thing that we know for sure is he's out
of New Orleans and when he does it it's
gonna be very nice Instagram farewell as
well Chris this basically is what he
said that that's big in the 20% yes was
Davis Davis did double back rich on on
and said all 29 teams but I took his
original comments that he said to the
assembled media that Boston was on the
list as being closer to the truth only
because you know being around the
organization a lot the summit's have
always been pretty confident that if
they retain Kyrie Irving that Anthony
Davis is going to want to play there now
if Kyrie goes they may not even make a
full
Fletch pitched Anthony Davis al-quran' 3
Davis because that won't be the
direction the team wants to go but if
they can retain Kyrie they have always
been really confident and they've done a
lot of research on this guy over the
last 18 months they've always been
really confident that Anthony Davis
walked the play with Kyrie Irving and
wants to play for a winner and Bach
offers both well and so I mean let's
just say something like that happens I
mean but why was Dell Demps fired Chris
I mean how is this his fault how could
how is this laid at his feet right now
I mean look the the current situation
maybe not Dell but remember he's been
there for like seven eight years and you
know for the entire Anthony Davis tenure
and he's traded away draft picks he's
made some bad draft picks he's made some
bad contract signings
I mean I don't know the Dells you know
that this was a you know at Anthony
Davis and his team led effort to kind of
force this this whole mess that turned
out to be but up until this point the
reason Anthony Davis or bigger than T
Davis wants out is because this team is
not they haven't built a winner around
it and and that that to me was was the
big reason why Dell was let go and I
look I said this weeks ago that if
you're gonna create Anthony Davis you
could either have to commit to Dell
Demps or find somebody else because you
do not want somebody making a Herschel
Walker type of deal that could read nap
your franchise or screw it up forever
you don't want that person to be a
temporary guy yeah I mean but who's
gonna say raise their hand and say I'll
take the job trading Anthony Davis and
and then deal with the oh I I think I
think it'll be a lot of people rich you
do I really need to be a lot of people
because this looki you know on the
surface it's not a great job but I made
the Herschel Walker
you know comparison look at the Dallas
Cowboys turned out to be after making
that deal I mean you are you're going to
get back the most substantial trade
package in NBA history
Alicia hood in terms of players draft
pick cap relief you're gonna have a
chance to revamp your team with the
assets Andrew Davis gets the point where
at this pelicans game if it feels done
right they could be in the playoffs in a
couple of years and they could be
trending towards a winning situation in
a few
years so I think it's got a lot more
appealing when people think okay and do
you think they end up getting a better
deal than the one that the Lakers put on
the table if they don't they'll get the
exact same deal
the Lakers aren't gonna you know screw
around with this and if they think
Boston's out look I mean look at what
could happen before a Laker deal gets
consummated what a Kawhi Leonard decides
to stay in Toronto is that going to
involve in another team any beat Chicago
you know Anthony Davis is from the area
maybe Chicago says look we'll put Lowry
market in and Chris Dunn and a few
graphics into it don't want it you don't
want to roll the dice if you're the
Lakers so at a bare minimum rich yeah I
think it's going to be the exact same
offer if not stronger get the pelicans
player right all right Maddox and before
I let you go I know you're not usually a
rumor monger
but I'm here to throw it out here what's
what's the craziest rumor you heard in
Charlotte with everybody they're in town
and all the agents and general managers
and members of the media just gossip
gossip gossip what's that I got to stop
you right there rich because with the
all-star with the trade deadline moved
up
I am formally done with all-star weekend
what do you mean so if you want to know
what the what if you wonder what the
weather was like in Saint Thomas over
the last four you you didn't go to the
all-star game huh it's just one it's
like Super Bowl it's just a big party
and that's fine but I'd rather go
somewhere you actually know you actually
used the break for yourself Chris really
I did I did I was selfish and I think I
wouldn't miss much in the buyout market
that turned out to be correct so missing
out on a great ending to the skills
competition there is an iron Chris and
Mannix and Illustrated right thanks for
Chris let's chat again soon certainly
when you come out here to Los Angeles as
I'm sure you will hey you got that si
Chris Mannix here in the Rich Eisen show
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience